hello everyone this next game was played
in 1991 in dos hermanas Spain and it was
the the first round of the tournament
Judas polar is playing against the
Viswanathan Anand and both Bolger and
Anand had a disasterous tournaments they
were only got three and a half out of
nine points the tournament was won by
Adams and I think chronic and Apollo
followed but the the dead tournament did
produced this great game and a lot of
people consider Judas polar to be the
the greatest female chess player to ever
live she defeated an international
master when she was ten years old and
she defeated her first Grandmaster when
she was 11 and she got her Grandmaster
title at 15 years of age sixteen years
and four months so even even before
Bobby Fischer so she was the youngest
Grandmaster ever to hold the title so
definitely a great chess player and I'm
interested if you agree with this claim
that the Judy bowler is the greatest
female chess player ever or do you think
maybe Holy One or someone else's is
better at the moment than she ever was
but okay let's see the game Judit Polgar
is white an arm is black and we have e4
c5 the Sicilian defense Knight to f3 d6
d4 seek a person d4 Mac a person d4
Knight f6 Knight to c3 and a6
the dnieper variation and the Bishop to
e3 we have e six by Anand and there's a
saying when on black plays d6 in the
Sicilian play d4 and the Judit Polgar
does she plays G for the Hungarian
attack
we have g5 by armed and now Knight to f5
and it's a it isn't considered good to
capture this night with the bishop is
this position will become crazy and
opened up and the world bishops will be
much better than nice in positions like
this so I don't plays g6 attacking the
knight but Judit Polgar doesn't go back
with the knife she plays g5 instead
attacking downs f6 Knight so on and
captures the knight she captures an f5
and in
set of capturing the night poker now
plays he captures on f6
and well this is unknown line and there
are all sorts of ideas in this in this
attack so another doesn't defend the
night he plays if a d5 because if he was
if he were to defend the nice guys can't
really go anywhere he can go here here
or here well he definitely doesn't want
to go back to where he came from
so it's something like Knight to d7
simply Queen to h5 and this is this is
beautiful for white a lot of ideas are
possible you can f6 and then completely
walking blacks position and even ideas
like g6 are possible so after he
captures on f5 and decided to play d5
now threatening b4 to protect the night
and the bishop and Judit Polgar plays
Queen to f3
we have d4 and now a queenside castle
now the night order Bishop cannot be
captured yes so a nun place at night B
to d7 and well now these and now both
Knights and the bishops are are able to
be captured so the Polgara plays Bishop
to d2 not capturing the night again
because it's G casters on f6 then simply
D captures on c3 and blacks attack would
happen much faster and black is much
better in this position so after Knight
B to D 6 we have Bishop to d2 around
captures D captures and c3 and Bishop
captures on c3 Bishop to g7 and now
again not capturing the night but your
displays rook the g1 and now if if this
night will be captured on the next
movies will be really hard for Adams to
Castle so Anand decides to do it right
away and well finally part with this f6
Knight so Judas plays G Casper's on f6
Queen Casper's on f6 and now Queen to
III and this Queen to III is the
preparing f4 but is f4 is the idea but
there is also a more significant threat
in this position if I were to play
something like b6 you know just to try
and develop the
this crook Kesterson d7 idea would be
deadly as better captures 97th and
simply visual captors on e5 and this is
completely winning for white the bishop
cannot be captured if the bishop is
captured
well then simply Queen captures on e5
and this Bishop is painted from Zurich
on g1
so after this Queen t3 move on and plays
the team to h8 now this idea is no
longer possible but he does have to
allow f4 so Judas place at f4 we have
Queen to b6 Queen to g3
now threatening checkmate on g7 so
Laurent has to go back and defend Queen
to h6 and rook 36 now offering the full
rook but this is what this route can be
captured as made follows on g7 so f6 and
this is a fierce attack and all of white
pieces are eyeing that g7 and the king
but f6 is a good move and on the defense
correctly and well black is okay here we
have a bishop back to D 2 and this
Bishop d2 this is the strongest move and
just finds it so unattested play e4 he
cannot allow this F to capture on e5 so
judges developed a Bishop to c4 we have
b5 and our Bishop to e6 attacking that
night twice
rook to a7 defending rook to c6 going
for more active Square with rook a5 and
now Bishop to e3 now attacking this rook
on a7 again so we have rope to b7 and
Bishop to d5 now threatening all sorts
of discoveries on the rook rook to b8
and now Joseph plays route to c7 so this
is a this is an awesome place for this
work b4 by Anand b3 and rook the v 5 now
attacking that bishop md5 and Bishop to
c6 and this is well it was really harder
for foreign lands rook to survive this
and well not now he got caught so he has
to play rook captures on f5 and we have
simply the row casters on c8 rook
captures on create 10 Bishop captures
and
attacking both Brooks here and here so
rook rook to c5 and Bishop captures an
f5 and broadcasters on f5 rook to d1
going for that route to d8 check on
place game to g8 and we have Queen to g2
and in this position well aren't
resigned because the well Anna's played
King to f8 but he people he touched the
King and he wanted to play King to f8
but then he didn't think he just he just
what resigned the game but anything
black plays here is completely losing it
even trying to play something like Queen
to g6 to just go for the exchange of
wind so loses the Queen captures to e4
and this rook the g1 is a devastating
move it is impossible to defend from
this if something like h6 rope the g1
Queen to h5 and now this is forcing
Queen to 8 check King to h7 and Queen to
a7 and there is no way to defend this in
this Bishop so yeah like I said both of
them had a pretty disastrous tournament
only three and a half out of nine points
and but we did get to see this game how
Judit Polgar crushes Viswanathan Anand
was somewhat older than her when this
game was played I think six years old
one that shirt and yeah definitely
definitely a great game and Arnold isn't
the only well he wasn't world champion
then but Anand isn't the only world
champion Joseph Borg are defeated I mean
there's I'm pretty sure there is a
no-one Judit Polgar hasn't defeated so
yeah now like I said in the beginning of
the video I'm interested what do you
think is Judit Polgar the greatest
female chess player ever
if so do share in the comments and as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here and this is thankful for
watching and I'll see you soon